on va tout de suite parlé avec stéphanie
maupas ce notre correspondante à la haye
bonjour stéphanie je ne sais pas si vous
m'entendez j'espère que vous m'entendez
oui je vous entends parfait
stéphanie quels sont les éléments dont
dispose la cour pénale internationale
cette enquête va porter sur les crimes
de guerre et des crimes contre
l'humanité qui auraient été commis
depuis presque dix ans puisque le
procureur enquête depuis les premières
manifestations qui avaient eu lieu dans
le centre de kiev en novembre 2013 et
ses enquêtes s'étendre aux crimes qui
sont éventuellement commis en ce moment
où au crime à venir il n'y a pas de
limite légale à ses investigations quand
vous l'avez rappelé un la russie n'a pas
adhéré à cette cour luttrell non plus
mais si le procureur la compétence et
bien c'est parce qu'en 2015 l'ukraine
lui avait demandé d'enquêter sur les
crimes commis sur son territoire et
depuis est bien la cpi mener un examen
préliminaire et évidemment les derniers
événements ont accéléré la décision
d'ouvrir une enquête lundi dernier le
procureur avait fait appel aux états en
leur demandant de le saisir pour pouvoir
accélérer la procédure 39 états l'ont
saisie alors tous les états de l'union
européenne plus onze autres états elle
ça a évité aux procureurs de devoir
déposer une requête avec des éléments de
preuve sur le bureau d'un juge une
requête qui aurait dû enfin il aurait
fallu du temps pour que cette requête
puisse être examinée examiné donc le
fait qu'il ait été saisi par des états a
accéléré la procédure mais dans le même
temps vous savez c est à 39 états se
sont essentiellement des états
occidentaux et donc pour démarrer cette
enquête et bien il ya une forme de
politisation de cette enquête à la cour
plutôt que l'obtention d'un saut
judiciaire d'une autorisation de la part
des juges mais quoi qu'il en soit karim
khan a indiqué hier que les enquêtes
pouvait démarrer que la collecte des
preuves pouvait débuter alors il faudra
évidemment du temps avant que les
premiers mandats d'arrêt puisse être
délivrés il faudra évidemment le temps
pour pouvoir faire cette enquête sur le
terrain pour le procureur de la cour
pénale internationale